i'm jim lebrecht
uh co-director co-producer of [ __ ] camp
i'm a
older white guy with long curly hair a
gray goatee
i've got a black shirt on with a little
white dots on it
behind me is a red wall with some
posters on it
i'm mary lampson i'm the co-editor of
[ __ ] camp
um working with eileen meyer and
andy gersh i'm an older
white woman with gray hair and i'm
wearing a black
i guess it's a shirt with a little bit
of purple on it
and i'm in a room which is my cutting
room which is full of posters
and has white walls yeah hi i'm nicole
newnam i'm the co-director and
co-producer of [ __ ] camp with jen
lebrecht and
um i am a middle-aged white woman with
blondish brown hair down to my shoulders
round glasses
inspired by judy humans and [ __ ] camp
and i am sitting next to a bookcase in
my home in oakland california
so as we opened here the uh people's
video theater who was a
this video group that happened to meet
everybody
from camp geneva gas station shows up in
the first thing they see
is that the camp is in disarray because
two counselors have gotten the crabs and
we've all been quarantined to our bunks
and about to shower with this wonderful
quell shampoo
go over there what's over there my girl
have you seen her today just from over
here have you talked to it
not really just from across here we're
all quarantined
it's our first it's our first week
anniversary today
it's your first weekend anniversary and
you can't even talk to him that's right
he loved the scene from the very
beginning it captures so much about the
community and spirit of the camp and
and it also is so iconoclastic it's not
all what you expect when you think about
what's going to be happening um you know
at a camp for the handicapped in in the
1970s
and we started actually thinking that we
would start the entire film
um with the scene but it ultimately um
became clear to us that what the scene
represented was the formation of a
of a bonded egalitarian community
um and going through something together
and so we ended up repositioning the
scene so that we're sort of building
towards that and it becomes a kind of
critical
step on the road to the journey that the
audience goes on along with jim
i think another reason that the film
that this
uh scene is sort of in the middle of
this section of the film is
you really have to the audience needs to
know these people in some way as
individuals so this is a group of people
that you're introduced
to gradually over the course of the
first i don't know
five six minutes and so that the
audiences really
really knows them and cares about them
and i think if you start with this scene
it would be just so
sort of shocking and disorienting that
it would
actually not draw the audience into the
film
that's incredible
you know i would love to have somebody
to wash your balls
right i can do it myself for me so you
know i don't really care
but there are other people who can you
know and they have to have it done for
him
there's a moment in the scene here would
leave me
where the tenor of the scene shifts and
it's very intentional the music shifts
the mood shifts
and what we're kind of doing is we're
we're bursting the bubble
we thought of this as a really important
moment in the narrative where we had
created the bubble of camp and at this
at this moment we're kind of puncturing
the bubble a bit and we're
starting to see how the campers are um
dealing with the with the outside world
i think actually what happened
was that people were having fun we were
working together
um as a whole unit washing and cleaning
and showering and doing things that
we've never done before and
it's really very different kind of a
thing and i have to go shower some
people
i'll see you later it's just so sort of
loving and if there's a line in it where
judy says
judy heumann says um it's the first time
i had to get used to somebody other than
my mother
taking care of me and you just feel that
in the way
that the campers and the counselors are
reacting to one another
in that swimming pool it's just
something very very beautiful
and that was something that i think we
saw right away in that
footage there were people there that
would
help me get dressed and undress and go
to the bathroom and shower get in and
out of the pool
and again you know i talk about humor or
i think about humor the attitude
of paul who had multiple disabilities
going on
modeled for me this wonderful way of
just being
he was just like oh well and it helped
me feel better about myself
there's a loose kind of disorganized
flowing sense of community
and that footage that the people's video
theater did such a beautiful job of
capturing
and it couldn't be over cut we had to
kind of feel that and i think the crabs
epidemic
gave us an opportunity to do that but at
the same time it's so intentionally cut
together and one of the beautiful things
that mary you did
was just build in these characters that
we kind of see
throughout the film over and over again
we don't just see them but we hear their
names
so even though they're minor characters
they're just people at the camp and they
never become a story point or part of
the narrative
but they become a part of what starts to
feel like a really multi-dimensional
world that we're immersed in
and so it boggles my mind actually the
extent to which you could take
this old footage and really make it feel
like a present day
immersive experience back home
i have to be careful who i said things
to
because that was a way of surviving
there were survival skills that you had
i had to be very very very careful not
to be disrespectful
not to look a white man in his eye you
had to do those things you had to be
mindful of that so at the end of
lionel's discussion of that comparing
the discrimination
that he experienced as a black man in
the south to the discrimination that he
saw people with disabilities facing when
they went into town to get an ice cream
say
i got so much things i don't know if i'm
really blue
cause i got the one time one time
whatever it is maybe we should start off
with um
overprotectiveness which i really hate
does anybody want to start my parents
are great
but sometimes i hate them because
they're too great and they're too
protective of me
which is really powerful because it's a
scene that literally was directed by the
campers in 1971 right jim
yeah when the people's video theater
came and taught us the first time they
said
look here's who we are help us make a
film about your camp
and so one of the things we asked was
we'd like to make a vid a film
about video that was near a lexicon
a film about uh our parents and how
they're
over protective and such and so
this scene which we call message to
parents
is a result of them asking us giving us
agency like
we didn't really experience from people
before well
some of the things like just everybody
else depends her parents for like
warning stuff but like
like she's the person that orders
special supplies when i'll need it and
stuff
and find a position where i'm unable to
do something
you know like she's gonna have to do it
and so like if you keep on [ __ ] you
this was a scene that the moment we saw
it jim and i
knew that we would be building a whole
first part of the film that was set at
the camp
up to this moment because it feels like
a moment of transformation and it feels
like a moment where
the community at camp has gelled and
people have moved into a
kind of a new way of thinking and being
this scene didn't really work until we
had
all the other scenes building up to it
working such that it felt like that
evolution towards a community had
happened but one of the things that i
really love about
this scene is how mary you pay such
incredible attention to it
yeah i think in the beginning you didn't
have a sense of the physical space
or it was sort of confusing because the
focus was primarily
sort of on jim and then obviously on
nancy
and then steve at the end but it was
hard to sort of
see the whole group so we just put a
couple of shots in
so you really understood that it was a
circle of people
sitting around a table having this
conversation it feels egalitarian right
i mean it feels like the spirit of the
kind of conversation that they're having
where they would
listen to nancy and that was something
that became really important later on in
the film when we go to the 504 sit-in
and we see that same kind of ethos
and set of values really expressed in
the sit-in and what made it successful
and what made the laws change and that
all had to be
communicated in this scene
yeah when we first watched this scene
we're like everybody else there we're
not quite sure
we really don't know what nancy is
saying and then we realized that
it would be interesting for our audience
to have the same experience
to be uncomfortable maybe not knowing
what she's saying because you know we
have
done subtitles for a lot of other people
who had disability affected speech
and that some folks would find hard to
understand
and it was the right decision i think
yeah when we showed this footage early
on to people they said there's no way
you can put this in the film it's going
to make people too uncomfortable
and so one of the beautiful things i
think about the way it's edited is that
you see these kind of like loving really
attentive
looks from multiple campers as nancy's
talking
and by the time you get to the scene
because
of the way that sense of community has
been constructed you
you have the patience as a viewer to
know already that you should be
respectful and listen and that nancy is
saying something
important and worth waiting for i think
um because of the way this scene is
constructed
the the is actually going through a
transformational experience
of having the patience to listen to
nancy and then learning through
the cooperative collaborative spirit of
the community
you know she's saying you know whatever
i'm doing she is there
basically i can't get away from i have
no time
just with myself and then what steve
is able to do in his translation is
basically just crystallize he doesn't
say and because her mom is there you
know she never has a moment but he's
taking that
idea and just condensing it into
three or four amazing you know what
words
so it's just like he because he
obviously
knows exactly what she's talking about
and i love the kind of just tenderness
of the kind of feeling um around the
table
um from everybody once she's spoken it's
it
really is like i think people people
realize that something important just
happened
really the disabled community i think
that well and i say the word community
really specifically because
i i think that what's so important to us
is that we do get a chance to come
together
and that perhaps that hasn't any
different from any other
group but that you know that
that often we often we are separated
we're isolated especially back then we
were so being able to come together at
this camp
and to learn from each other and
experience and to love each other
um was was was rather was rather rare